convicted rapist Harvey Weinstein will
find out today how long he will spend in
prison
Weinstein faces up to 29 years on Monday
the court unsealed his personal emails
part of a trove of more than a thousand
pages of documents our national
correspondent Jericka Duncan is outside
the Manhattan Court where he will be
sentenced today tarika good morning good
morning that sentencing will happen here
on the 15th floor but later today again
on the eve of the day that he is set to
be sentenced we learned new information
including how someone very close to
Harvey Weinstein believed that the
disgraced movie mogul was a sexual
predator the newly released documents
give a glimpse into Weinstein's mental
state in the months after women began
coming forward in a draft email
statement in 2017 Weinstein claimed he
was suicidal he later went on to commend
the journalists who exposed him writing
as hard as it is for me to lose
everything I know they fought for
something that's important as did the
women the documents also revealed tense
emails from Weinstein's brother and
former business partner Bob in emails in
2017 Bob told his brother
I pray there is a real hell that's where
you belong
that same year Weinstein wrote an email
to his representative that said jennifer
aniston should be killed that email came
after the National Enquirer claimed it
was going to publish a story saying
Weinstein sexually assaulted Aniston her
representative says the allegations were
not true in a letter to the judge
Tuesday Weinstein's defense attorneys
asked for leniency saying the trial did
not fairly portray who he is as a person
but prosecutors argued Weinstein conduct
shows him to be a serial sexual abuser
CBS News legal analyst Ricky Clemens
said she does not think Weinstein will
get the five-year minimum sentence I
believe the judge will be very harsh on
Harvey Weinstein the judge cannot forget
that he has already heard the testimony
of six accusers so I do not expect the
judge to be
terribly lenient with mr. Weinstein it's
unclear if Weinstein plans to speak at
his sentencing we know that his lawyer
said that he will appeal this verdict
and remember Harvey Weinstein is still
facing charges in Los Angeles it is
unclear when the district attorney plans
to move forward in that case Anthony
Jericka thank you